so
goodbye
[Music]
yes
is
down
[Music]
see
so
clear the line of attack the energy
[Music]
over here
there you go down
brown you don't need to grab the
necklace
get my elbow in front of your weight i'm
gonna help you
elbow goes in the front hemisphere
hemisphere try the technique
go go you're never going to get it
elbow on the front hemisphere go
[Music]
yield um
it's all weak
that's it
there you go
it's got to end up there
[Music]
yep
there you go
me
[Music]
already in place
lock
[Music]
got it
there you go
what happens
move your is body
don't let the pain shut you down
[Music]
no
in your mind is
doing get ready to get set go and that's
not the warrior
okay here we go
you don't have to go fast you just have
to find that inner stillness
in the body in the body
[Music]
all right
and done
feel it until you feel it no more you
can keep moving so you don't feel that
pressure right there
low it's close you see it increased on
you
it's out more it's out
there that's it don't put it back don't
push on it you push
on it
[Music]
zero zero wait for it to come to you
then in the bottom don't push against
it in the body on the kazushi angle
[Music]
and one more
pressure off you're going to need
another step
there you go
[Music]
it's just loose
okay and then you're trying to shove
with your arms
on your body together to you you see
that
not not push my arm together to you
body
[Music]
yield body
oh
hug you it's hugging you
get that elbow in the front hemisphere
of your body
that's it energetic
[Music]
try to do the lock now you're not going
to get it
there's no leverage there okay mine keep
moving
don't let the hand wrap on my back
move myself that's where i go
and keep this up off my back
[Music]
i haven't even done the move yet why
don't i do that
don't lower that line
there's some sanctuary and the angles of
cancellation
you have to have those are
and then i'm not going to bring you
around
[Music]
okay
oh
yields
[Music]
try to get up
it's not here
remove disappear
angle okay
okay so this right now is
what you want to do you fill out the
technique you're about to do a bambi
roll do you see that
look dope do it
come back hence
here you see see my elbow
right it does the difference
oh you counted the technique i counted
it
okay well maybe you don't like what that
is on your shoulder
and move your body instead dive
without doing that
forward
with the disappear
down now look where i am here
okay
[Music]
doing it wrong
okay give me some energy and i'm gonna
move you
you stay with me you're pushing on me
stay with me don't push on me
don't don't do anything
right there there it is you take it
nope you want me to go backwards or
forward
forward i'm going to give it to you
again don't push on me i'm going to give
you
i'm
there it is we it's going to go that way
and down that's it and disappear
don't eat me that's it down i go
go back ed me
and down that's it now don't go like
this
[Music]
relax
okay get it in the right place
hug yourself
and bow
put my hand against your head okay
here here right
here
there it is
move your body that way if you want your
hands to face put your body
there it is don't push on me because i'm
stronger than you
stay outside stay outside at the
energetic
limits and guide that limit
down that's it around here i go down
in place time time see how it's not
tight
tight to you type to you
no get your posture
get your posture put my elbow on the
front hemisphere
stop i'm gonna move i'm gonna help you
please over here keep this up
to you you moved yourself back
all right let's try your way go so
what's happening not enough leverage
so stay still i'm going to move myself
into the right place here
see my elbow there cut it elbow
there now get your posture so my hand is
off my back
don't pull me up just hug it to your
posture
my elbows against your body now move my
elbow
so my shoulder mechanism goes down into
the mat not around my shoulders
there you go
what was that
okay so you have the guy down
and you're not you're not trying to uh
dislocate his arm
you're trying to pin this corner trying
to put
pressure weight energy there
so when you get here
don't try to turn his arm he's he's much
stronger than me
don't let me turn your arm
it's not going to happen okay just
straighten your arm if you want
straighten it
straighten it up do you see okay
also my
[Music]
tai sabaki my body work should be
redundant with my tessabaki
which means i can take one away and
still have the same
outcome if i if i'm here like this
and i take away my tesabaki you don't
have the same outcome
okay so this elbow goes here
in front of my hemisphere my front
hemisphere
to the left in this case of my spine
and i'm not trying to bend his arm i'm
trying to use
we didn't get on me you can tap when you
want
to push this whole shoulder mechanism
down into the mat the reason i'm holding
his arms is
so that the body can do its job okay
it's redundant with what the body
is doing but you can see you don't need
you don't need that okay
but over here you do need it over here
you're very arm dependent
in a in a place from which your arms are
very
much at a mechanical disadvantage okay
so the elbow goes on the front
and my goal is through this leverage
system
to push the whole shoulder mechanism
down boom okay
not to turn him don't lower the hand
because that's the opposite
there's less pressure on your shoulder
isn't it you got to keep the hand where
it is
oh if you lower the hand again you see i
don't have it i don't have it
the hand has to be at this angle so that
my body could have done it by itself
and i'm here
so the goal is shoulder mechanism be
pressed into the mat
not trying to do some sort of
elbow lock or some sort of pain
compliance okay